Congress paying its respects as well the
house is delaying votes and scheduled
testimony during the tributes to
President Bush Nancy Cordes is here on
Capitol Hill and see good morning
there's still a lot of work for Congress
to get done this week it's supposed to
be a busy week it was supposed to be a
busy week not anymore President Bush did
manage to being bring Congress together
in one respect Nora and that is that
leaders agreed to a two-week government
funding deal in order to head off a
bitter spending fight and the prospect
of a partial shutdown next week now they
did that because the focus this week is
really on the former president lying in
state here at the Capitol and now
they'll have time to debate a long-term
spending plan after his casket departs
it's still a pressing issue though
president Trump has said he's open to a
government shutdown if he doesn't get
more funding for a southern border wall
funeral arrangements for mr. Bush have
also postponed key testimony in front of
the House Judiciary Committee by former
attorney general Loretta Lynch and
Google CEO sundar pichai both of those
hearings could be rescheduled for next
week Medora when it comes to government
funding this delay really does put
Congress's back up against the wall if
they don't come to an agreement by
December 21st they could be looking at a
working holiday all right Nancy Cordes
thank you so much